this is a production of cornell
university
hello and thank you for choosing to see
my talk about the definition of genes
for
organelle specifically
plastomphylogenomics
the paper i'll be summarizing is now in
press and systematic biology
let me start by providing some
background
in an important paper in 2009 scott
edwards announced the advent of the
species tree paradigm in molecular
systematics
its central dogma was the insight from
population genetics going back to the
1980s
that gene trees are not species trees
the corollary to this dogma is that gene
trees will disagree with one another due
to drift
this leads to lineage sorting but
incongruence can only occur if the genes
are unlinked
if recombination has made them
independent of one another
it is recombination therefore that
defines the units of phylogeny as has
been recognized for many years
following hudson's work in the 80s and
90s showing the complexity of historical
relationships of genes due to
recombination
i termed these phylogenetic units
coalescent genes or c genes for short
a simplified example of hudson's inside
is shown here for a single locus with
four alleles
a to d with a gene tree shown
recombination between non-sister alleles
a and c
leads to a recombinant allele characters
one to eight trace the origin of the
five prime portion of the allele to the
a allele
whereas the three prime portion of the
allele shares a history with allele c
there are thus two different histories
two different c genes
created by recombination
in that example recombination split a
functionally defined gene into two c
genes with high enough recombination
every nucleotide of a gene may have a
different history
maybe a separate c gene at the other end
of the spectrum
as the rate of recombination decreases
multiple linked molecular genes share
the same history comprising a single c
gene with no recombination the entire
genome can be a single historical unit
a single c gene it is the amount of
recombination
not functional definitions that
determines the size of the c gene
both ends of this spectrum of
recombination represent key assumptions
for species tree estimation
under the multi-species coalescent as
stated recently by bravo at all
each c gene must represent a potentially
independent
single uniform estimate of the species
tree
so there must be free recombination
between c genes
and no recombination within a c gene
to recap then too much recombination
violates the assumption that a single
molecular gene
is a suitable c gene at the other
extreme
assuming that each gene in a
non-recombining block is a separate c
gene violates the other recombination
assumption of free recombination
which is to say the ability of the c
gene to provide an independent estimate
of the species tree
this brings me to organelle genomes
it has been widely accepted as i wrote
many years ago that with no effective
recombination the c
gene can be an entire genome as is the
case of organelle or genomes
this remains a mainstream assumption in
coalescent theory as seen in this recent
quote from magnus nordborg
that mitochondrial dna represents a
single locus
for coalescent purposes there are
dissenters however
a recent paper by a distinguished group
of systematists on rosid phylogeny using
whole plastome sequences
reported incongruence among
protein-coding genes
incongruence is a hallmark of
recombination as i've mentioned
so they hypothesize that incongruence
could be due to historical independence
of plastid genes
caused by recombination consequently
they
analyzed their data using msc methods
an overlapping group of authors
published a node in mpe with a very
provocative title
in it they made the case that
accumulating knowledge of organelle
biology has been ignored even willfully
swept under the rug
by molecular systemitis resulting in
misrepresentation
misconceptions and the misuse of
organelle genomes in phylogenetic
studies what are these misconceptions
first that plastoms are circular and
don't recombine
second that heteroplasmy is rare and can
be ignored
third that plastids are universally
strictly maternally inherited
and the first three of these together
contribute to the last one most critical
for phylogeny reconstruction
that the plastome is a single coalescent
gene
i disagree with the authors on that
conclusion so let's explore these issues
point by point
plastoms have indeed been represented as
circles and this convention
continues but there's been disagreement
about this for over 30 years mainly from
arnold bendich who calls circular
chloroplast genomes the grand delusion
for phylogeny reconstruction it does not
matter how the genes of a plasma
represented of course
but what does matter is recombination
bendaget's models require
considerable intermolecular
recombination but recombination
albeit intramolecular is also part of
the circular model going back to the
1970s
and 1980s so the ability
of the plastome to recombine has never
been disputed
but the key point is not that is that
not all recombination is
is relevant it must be what i call
historically effective
and this is something that many authors
have pointed out over the years
here for example is a quote from cecile
n a some recombination events do not
affect the gene tree or its branch
lengths
indeed she continues it is advantageous
to concatenate neighboring sites
that have the same history to see what
she means
here is the earlier example i showed but
this time instead of modeling a
recombination event between alleles a
and c
which are non-sisters on the tree we
follow a recombination event
between sister alleles a and b clearly
this has no effect on the topology
and this is exactly the situation when a
mutation occurs in a plastid within a
plant cell i show this here as a
plastometer within a green plastid
experiencing a mutation
transforming the green plastid to white
the alleles will be sisters on the
phylogeny and so recombination between
them
occurring within the plastid where the
mutation occurred
will not affect the phylogeny what a
mutation in a plastone within a nucleoid
within a plastid will do
is to make a homoplasmic cell
heteroplasmic
which brings me to the next alleged
misconception
clearly heteroplasmy is not rare it is a
necessary consequence of mutation and
recombination
this has not been swept under the rug
but heteroplasmy caused by mutation in a
plastid
does not involve historically
differentiated plastoms and does not
produce incongruence
this requires hybridization which brings
me to the next misconception
that plastids are universally strictly
maternally inherited
for hybridization to bring together
historically differentiated plastoms
both parents must transmit their
plastids
it has been known for over 30 years that
many angiosperms are potentially capable
of biparental transmission this classic
paper suggested 14 percent of genera and
around 20 percent of families
but by parental transmission though
necessary is not sufficient to produce
incongruence through recombination
for recombination to affect phylogeny
reconstruction historically
differentiated plastoms must be brought
together
once there it is likely that they will
recombine
but this requires two things first that
a cell be heteroplasmic
with plastids bearing historically
differentiated plastones
but as vaughn noted in 1981 vegetative
segregation into pure cell lines is so
fast that such heteroplasmy is a
transient phenomenon
this rapid sorting out is what leads to
many variegated leaf phenotypes
it also requires that historically
differentiated plastoms be brought
together in the same nucleoid within the
same plastid
and as magesi at all noted in 1985 this
requires plastid fusion
which is a very rare phenomenon
consequently as they hypothesize
chloroplast dna recombination is rare
because plastid
fusion is rare
so in my opinion the plastom is still
best thought of as a single c
gene historically effective
recombination if it occurs at all
is likely to fall at the far end of the
recombination spectrum
where there is risk of violating the key
assumption of free recombination between
c genes so how much of a problem is
violation of recombination assumptions
for msc methods
turning first to the too much
recombination violation
simulations by lanier and knowles in
2012 and by wang and liu
in 2016 suggested that msc methods are
robust to some within locus
recombination on the other hand wang and
liu tested the too little recombination
assumption
and found that this has major
consequences on the accuracy of
phylogeny reconstruction under the msc
gonsalves at all recommend breaking the
plastum into multiple genes
putitive c genes but defined
functionally ndhf rbcl etc
they thus focus on this unlikely and
lower impact risk
but they are unconcerned about this
highly probable
major impact risk as it turns out their
recommendations of msc methods over
concatenation is somewhat ironic
reason i say this is because there's
been a heated debate about c
gene definition edwards and colleagues
in song at all 2012 conducted an msc
analysis of 447 mammalian nuclear
transcripts averaging 3.1 kb
by concatenating exons from genes
averaging about 140 kb
springer and gates derided this as what
they called concatelescence
and called into question the
implementation of msc in general
referring to it as the gene tree
delusion
edwards had all defended the procedure
citing among other things the linear
null simulation study showing that some
recombination is not a fatal problem for
species tree inference
and they defended the entire msc
paradigm
the typical angiosperm plastum is about
the same size as the average mammalian
gene used by song at all
but is far more densely packed with
genes than those genes
are with exons consequently one would
expect less recombination between
plastid genes than between these nuclear
exons
particularly considering the low
historically effective recombination
rate as i've discussed
the arguments of gonsalves at all
clearly echoed those
of springer and gates they contend there
is too much recombination within what
others have defined as a single c
gene yet they cite edwards at all as the
authority of orthodox application
of msc theory that's ironic
given all of this i do not believe that
gonsalves at all have made a strong case
for the plastomas comprising multiple c
genes this brings me to the final topic
of the talk
the theory and practice of phylogenomics
gonsalves at all suggests that
acceptance of the plastom is a single c
gene not only is a misconception but is
still being employed to justify the
importance of nuclear datasets
but have nuclear genes ever needed
justification for inferring species
trees
i don't believe so clearly the nuclear
genome can be assumed to comprise a
large number of sea genes
the plastom has only been used because
of its desirable technical properties
high copy number and its ability to
produce a robust tree through
concatenation
so now that nuclear genes are readily
available the question that i think
should be asked
is in practice what should the role of
plastom sequences be for hypothesizing
species relationships
gonsalves all argue that it should be
sufficient to sequence some number of
plastid genes and use them directly not
by concatenation
which in the msc paradigm is an
admission that only a gene tree is being
constructed
but by using msc approaches i believe
this would bring the
wheel the field full circle back to the
days before the difference between gene
trees and species trees was understood
and appreciated in plant systematics
the alternative is some combination of
plastid sequences with nuclear sequences
concatenation as noted is not favored
under the msc paradigm
and treating individual plastome genes
as equivalent to nuclear genes ignores
their likely linkage again violating the
free recombination assumption
so in my opinion best practice should
follow theory
treat the plastum as equivalent to any
other single c gene
regardless of how robust a hypothesis
hypothesis it provides
and combine it with nuclear genes each
of which is also assumed to be a c
gene so i want to leave you with a final
thought
courtesy of the great baseball
philosopher yogi bera
in theory there is no difference between
theory and practice
but in practice there is in practice
many plant molecular systemitis continue
to invest a great deal of effort
in plastomphylogenies which if one
believes the theory
provides a single gene estimate of the
species tree
i ask you does that make sense
thank you a reminder that the paper
should soon be available in systematic
biology
i'd like to acknowledge a number of
people i'm grateful in particular to
daisy gonzalez
bob jansen and tracy reulman for raising
this interesting question and discussing
it with me
and to the many people who contributed
in one way or another to the paper
thanks again
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu